this is a fox news alert
prince william responding to a bombshell
case
of media malpractice involving his
mother
princess diana an investigation is found
that
bbc reporter martin beshear used quote
deceitful tactics
in order to secure a landmark tell-all
interview with princess diana back in
1995.
benjamin hall is standing by in london
with all the details benjamin
jesse good afternoon yes you'll remember
this interview from 1995. it was
groundbreaking the first time princess
diana had spoken publicly
about the breakdown of her marriage to
prince charles about his adultery with
camilla parker-bowles in fact she said
in the interview
there were three of us in this
relationship it just didn't work
she spoke about her rampant bulimia and
many people feel that this interview
uh led to events that led to her death a
couple of years later well what it is
now
uh what has now emerged is that she gave
that interview
after being shown forged bank documents
which made it look as if members of the
royal household were being paid
to spy on her prince william released
this statement just in the last few
minutes saying
it is my view that the deceitful way the
interview was obtained
substantially influenced what my mother
said the interview was a major
contribution to making my parents
relationship worse
and has since hurt countless others it
brings indescribable sadness to know
that the bbc's failures
contributed significantly to her fear
paranoia
and isolation that i remember from those
final years with her
it was always thought strange that
princess diana chose martin beshear
a relatively young unknown journalist to
do this interview it's now clear she did
so
because he duped her and had asked the
bbc graphics team
to draw up these fake documents to
convince her some have compared that
1995 diana interview to the one prince
harry recently gave to oprah they both
talked about how hard they found royal
life
and how it affected their mental health
but an incredibly
open personal letter from prince william
in the last few moments
he has often said that he felt the media
hounded his mother
well this letter goes a little bit
further and said had she known about the
deceit at the time
things may have turned out very
differently jesse
thanks fan hang tight we want to ask you
a few questions dana perrino
go right ahead well jesse i know you are
an expert on this uh case so i'm glad
you tossed it to me just kidding um
i do have some questions benjamin first
of all why in the world
would the diana's team the pr team
i'm sure she's not making these
decisions on her own have asked for
you know bank records why how does that
happen
well first of all her team was actually
quite diminished at the time the royal
family by all accounts had rather
cut her off and she was left with quite
a small team her brother being the main
one
and this journalist martin bashir
approached the brother saying
i've come across these documents which
show that members of your household
and of princess diana's household have
been accepting money totaling about ten
thousand pounds
about fifteen thousand dollars to give
uh
information on her life uh to both the
tabloids as well as to the security
services
and it was that piece of information
that encouraged diana to go with martin
bashir it was right
widely reported that she was wanting to
give an interview anyway
but certainly not to this young bashir
and certainly the interview would not
have been many people think
uh as groundbreaking as such a big open
honest interview as she gave but she was
very angry
with the reports uh that martin bashir
brought to her
but what about this report that there
was a handwritten note that she wrote
that said she was happy with the
interview yeah she
she did and that's what martin bashir
continually brings up but that's because
there
had not been an investigation at the
time the bbc
had an internal investigation which
showed uh martin bashir was at fault
here but they
held that they covered it up they didn't
release it um
so the feeling is at the moment that
princess diana just didn't realize the
true extent of the fraud that was played
on her
um that's being said i mean i just think
that the
cl you know i think it diminishes her uh
intelligence and her she was clever and
she was smart and she was an intelligent
woman
and she put it out there that there were
three people in the marriage
and maybe that was hurtful maybe that
led to additional things but
it just seems to me that if you give an
interview to a reporter at least
here they would just be a little bit
different thanks benjamin
thanks dana kennedy would you like to
ask benjamin a question yes uh you know
oftentimes we have saying obviously uh
the ends justify the means uh but the
means were fraudulent
and the end was utterly tragic for this
woman
can you put into context how
she obviously was the brightest burning
royal
at the time there was years and years of
gossip
about the whale's marriage but when that
fell apart and this interview came out
before the earth before they were
divorced
how did that interview change how she
was pursued by the press
cook and and how does that uh lead into
her son's reaction yeah it played into
it in a big way and you're right she was
the shining star of the royal family at
the time and frankly many people have
said that
prince charles in particular really
didn't didn't like that he couldn't
stand it he was the heir to the throne
he was the one that was supposed to get
all the attention
and princess diana was the the people's
princess she was the one that people
turned to
and so when the the divorce or when the
marriage broke down
uh people started to side with her and
they didn't like that and then
as soon as she spoke to the press you
kind of crossed that line your royals
tend to be given some sort of privacy in
the uk they certainly did in the 90s but
when she came out and gave that big
interview it was
almost as if the gloves came off and
that she was fair game for the rest of
the press and it really was that point
that we started to see them
hound her not just one or two paparazzi
but
hundreds and hundreds at a time
following her everywhere she went and
she was not given support or security
by the royal family that's what she
argues the counter side to this
is that she very cleverly used the media
she knew she was heading into a divorce
battle she knew that she needed to
improve her own standing and become the
people's princess and so she was often
known to give tips off
uh tip-offs to the media and to the
tabloids when it suited her
and then also didn't want the attention
uh when it was bad so you know there are
two sides to how princess diana
interacted with the media but certainly
there is no excuse for the kind of
journalistic malpractice that comes with
forging documents
uh to get an interview
juan williams why don't you jump in here
all right so you know this week there
was news here in the u.s when
uh prince harry i guess said you know he
thinks the first amendment here in the
united states is
confusing to him he doesn't understand
it and i know that fleet street is
famous
in britain for its aggressive tactics
uh you know tapping phones and all the
rest
but is there a different set of rules
just for us as americans to understand
as we take in this story or
is there a different set of protections
for uh public figures like diana that
are being applied now in this bbc report
well you know certainly there was an
understanding between the papers and the
royal family that
the two princes would give x amounts i
think was only a few
um media events a year and in exchange
they would be given their privacy and
that's been a long standing agreement
between the press and the and the
princes over here in the royal family
that started to change and i think we've
seen that the world over social media
also started to mean that
uh and of course that came a bit later
but they were everywhere
and paparazzi the 90s was the heyday of
paparazzi and these pictures were being
sold in other countries so the uk press
could no longer control it and there was
a big discussion as to whether these
if these photos that were being taken so
often princess diana were being
published around the world
well why should the uk press also have
to uh why should the uk press have to be
silenced and not be able to publish them
and so we started to see a relationship
change between the royal family
and the media but yes you talk about
prince harry and i think you know many
people say that he is just as
uh as savvy as his mother was when it
comes to using uh and playing with the
media and we've seen that now
he called the first amendment bonkers i
think it was
and it's surprising that prince william
was the first one to come out with a
statement because it is almost
always harry who is quickly on instagram
or twitter
with his replies interestingly we will
see the two brothers together
on the first of july because it would
have been princess diana's 60th
birthday and they're unveiling a statue
together and it'll be the first time
that we've seen them since prince
philip's funeral
and since the big rift has continued to
widen so all eyes will be on that but
it seems like there are two different
camps at the moment you have william who
often comes out with these
uh rather more uh restrained statements
then you have harry with these far more
emotional ones and some people feel that
he's really following the diana model
but this statement today from prince
william
uh was emotional and raw to the core and
he talked about the pain and always the
suffering
that this interview caused him uh so i
think we're seeing a game play out
between the two
the two of them you prince william
doesn't want prince harry to be the one
who carries the mantle of
his mother he wants to say to remind the
world that she was his mother too and he
has just as much of a right over her
so it's an interesting battle playing
out between the two brothers so we'll
all be watching
when they come back together again on
july the 1st
yeah william's statement actually
included the phrase fake news
which i had to do a little bit of a
double take there
i didn't know that had become so popular
across the pond benjamin
kdp would like to ask you a question so
stick right there katie
so benjamin you're mentioning this
rivalry that seems to be brewing between
the two brothers and color me suspicious
but
this was an independent inquiry so can
you please talk about who was behind
the independent inquiry because this
interview took place 26 years ago
and now you have harry in the u.s
working with oprah
there was a headline this week saying he
was going to drop more truth bombs
about the royal family so who was behind
the investigation and why is it coming
out now
yeah there have long been rumors that
this interview was based on fraudulent
reporting the bbc did its own internal
investigation about 25 years ago and
they covered it up
uh this new um investigation came along
it's called the dyson inquiry headed up
by lord dyson who's a you know a
well-known
uh legal figure over here and it came
about just because of the changes in the
media that we're seeing
uh we had the phone hacking scandal
which took place you know 10 years or so
we've seen a number of cases brought
back
and reinvestigated this has been one of
them and
as a result this has come to light and
it has now been accepted by the bbc who
have always denied it and whether there
will be ramifications we just don't know
at the moment but the press really are
being held to account
more and more over here um yeah i think
you mentioned the phone hacking
um which took place around 10 years ago
that absolutely changed the way the
media was seen over here it was the wild
west for them
they were they were you know hacking
into prince harry's
voicemails because a lot of these
voicemails were just generic passwords
um and all this information was being
splashed over the newspapers and they
really cracked down
on that and what we're seeing now
frankly is
the media continuing to try and clean
itself up and perhaps address
old mistakes thanks a lot benjamin
i guess it's true that media corruption
has no borders
and prince harry has released a
statement saying quote
to those who have taken some form of
accountability
thank you for owning it that is the
first step towards
justice and truth yet what deeply
concerns me is that practices like these
and even worse are still widespread
today then
and now it's bigger than one outlet one
network
or one publication my biggest concern
was history repeating itself
i've said that before on numerous
occasions very publicly
and what i was seeing was history
repeating itself
but more perhaps or definitely far
more dangerous because then you add race
in
and you add social media in and when i'm
talking about history repeating itself
i'm talking about my mother
very interesting that he would say that
at this point and we will leave it at
that hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else